alex would love to hear uh about your
journey
and how you also came to join this
coalition of mayors for guaranteed
income
holyoke's a city of 40 000 people right
outside springfield and i say it's a
a small city with big city challenges we
were once the
paper city of the entire country the
first planned industrial city
in in the united states and because the
forces of capitalism and globalization
we
fell on hard times those factories
shuttered jobs moved down south and
overseas at the very time new people
came to our community
and today we're we're largely we're 50
latino
mostly of puerto rican descent and the
jobs that were once available to irish
immigrants and polish immigrants
were not available to puerto rican
migrants in our in our community and so
for years policymakers and mayors have
struggled with well how do we
create jobs and build wealth for people
in our community and
when i think about the the fact that we
focus on entrepreneurship and build and
wealth building opportunities for
for people in our community not not sort
of seeking large corporations coming in
so our residents can make minimum wage
jobs but how do we give people the tools
they need
to start their own business and build
wealth for themselves and for their
families
it's why i'm a strong supporter of a
single-payer healthcare system
and why i'm a strong supporter of a
guaranteed income
in the middle of this pandemic while our
federal government seems more concerned
with you know bailing out corporations
and
institutions and businesses you know we
need to fight for a people's bailout
people here in holyoke we already have a
high population of folks that are food
insecure
housing insecure that are concerned with
how to put food on the table and pay
their rent
pay their mortgage and now with the like
incredible
reduction in the economy the fact that
our economy shrunk by what over 33
in the last quarter our gdp by 10 our
economy is not going to return to the
way it was before
and so we were already forced to
redefine what
what productivity was who capitalism was
serving
and now it's even more pronounced um in
in communities like holyoke
and communities across the country and
so this is really about you know as
as mayor brown said basic humanity and
dignity for our people
and what choices people can make like
can you start that business
can you be a mother or a father and and
and and take care of your kids at the
same time or do you have to choose
between working
to provide for your family or being
there for your child
and and no person in this country and
the wealthiest country on earth should
have to make that decision
and clearly we're ill-prepared in terms
of policy and legislation to meet
families
where they're at and i'm running against
a member of congress that
takes the most amount of corporate money
of any member of the house democrat
and republican he just took the top spot
away from republican kevin mccarthy
and that's from wall street and big
pharma and pharmaceutical companies
and he's even again publicly denounced
and come out against the paycheck
guarantee act
he's come out against monthly recurring
emergency payments throughout the
duration of this pandemic
and even has a gall to site that cite
the deficit you know something
oftentimes reserved for
folks on the right and so he just fails
to meet the urgency of this moment
and you know it's time we actually send
unbought democrats
to washington it's not enough to be a
democrat you have to be a democrat that
actually wants to represent and fight
for people
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode